in studio we have the birthday boy with
maurice ashley wesley
happy birthday thank you for all the
birthday greetings everyone who greeted
me today uh arbiters the players
let me say happy birthday as well yeah
thank you i mean the last thing i want
to do is play chess on my birthday
very glad tomorrow is a rest day so also
that's one of the reasons why i decided
to play a bit safe today because the
last thing you want is to lose on your
birthday
i'm sure the last thing you want to hear
also is that rook d1 would have probably
won the game i saw it outside yeah
yeah the thing is
yeah if five was a howler i mean it's a
blunder obviously
but
i i just think rook d1 i thought h3 also
was getting bit low on time that's what
the reason why i took on d6
but um
yeah it's very weird actually rook d1
wins by fourth
but you kind of have to see king he won
a three moves later
like it's all fours king f1
knight e3 f e3 queen h2 like you have
the freaking e1 otherwise if
if you play something else like bishop
e4 which looks very natural actually
loses fifth rook h3
uh sorry how does it lose wesley rook h3
right here right now yay
wow we were looking at ideas with knight
c4 but rook h3 tried to find a defense
but i didn't see it obviously wow but
you needed to see spot kingy one right
which yeah yeah yeah that's much more
clean that's the right move yeah right
somehow rook t1 or k6 yeah rugby one
okay chicks king f1 can be seen
but in knight e3 is the only move
because if you don't take on e3 then
bishop e4 protects everything
yeah i guess i just didn't see it that
you run the king dance yeah the kingdom
yeah the bishop e4 you're like super
safe the other move that uh
fabi himself had trouble explaining he
did see rook g1
and he thought that was good for you too
did you see rook g1
yeah i saw rook g1 but actually after
de5 if you let the engine run for a long
time it's not very clear okay i think
white is
better but not that much better because
the knights are well placed
like i was analyzing queen fit2 yep
which is the number one move of the
engine by the way black plays g6
and um it's not
not i mean white is better but also i
have two double pumps so this is this is
not winning
maybe like rook d1 or some d1
because now that you've provoked g6
there's no
rook
uh
attacks yeah yeah but if not
it's not winning this position after f5
wow
two bishops your bishop on a1 is alive
yeah yeah that's true but also the
double bonds
remarkable like a some counterplay like
finished seven but yeah rugby one was
the missed chance but uh tell us were
you thinking when you took on d6 that
you were relying upon uh ideas of bishop
e5 as a defense yeah yeah i thought it
was winning at first but black manages
to save himself with queen g5 and queen
h5 right there because now rook 86 is a
threat so we have to
take the draw exactly yeah and then
i had 25 minutes for 20 moves so i
thought i'll just force the draw
but because my first intention was
instep it takes d6 my first intention
was a move like h3
but after d5 white could even be worse
so
because my bishop a1 is quite passive
[Music]
so but yeah i didn't see i didn't see my
book the one
but the opening was very interesting
like also rookie eight i didn't
analyze through e8
from the early get-go yeah and then this
idea with b5 is fantastic i think i
shouldn't have allowed the double pawns
i should play bishop e2
were you familiar with b5
uh
i'm familiar with the idea it looks very
strong and it's the best move for black
so after
a5 maybe b
b5 is interesting
[Music]
but
yeah either case i think life manages
not very big
i think here
and i should play bishop e2 instead
fabi uh praised your bishop d3 because
he felt that in the game had you played
bishop e2 he wanted to play bishop d7
yeah so he thought when you played
bishop d3 and he played bishop b7
he was actually
afraid that you would go back with a
bishop and
because you're so you're a genius for
having learned the bishop to beast oh
yeah
he thought that was very clever of you
he yeah he intended to meet bishop e2
with bishop to d7 yes and he thought
that knight d7 and queen b8 he would
round up
the b pawn yeah castle queen b8 roxy one
knight bd5 quincy iv
this was probably one of his
main
positions yeah yeah he's right it's
probably just equal also
so in the opening
i got played better maybe b4 was not the
best move there okay maybe
but uh yeah i mean the thing is like i
never expected to play e5 later on in
the end like i was expecting f5 right ah
so when he made the blunder e5 i just
didn't know what to think anymore
how did you intend to meet fight by the
way he had his id ideas yeah the idea
through get faith i was gonna play rook
g1
g1 rook fade queen b2
the idea circuit 16 h1 this was the
exact
concept that he thought he thought that
you would get to a position of stasis
and that somehow
the double pawns it would be like a good
blockade but a likely
troll yeah
but the engine is giving blacks better
i'm not sure why
likes the knights
likes the bishop on a1
really great bishop yeah i was going to
play something like this but obviously i
missed f5 a few months ago
right
but
yeah f5 was what i was expecting
yep
wesley uh
we all hate playing our birthdays yeah
like when you know
you got to play a big game like today
does it
what do you do to switch outs he said
okay i i do have to play and i know it's
it's almost
uh
what it what do we call it when when uh
it's the day when we're
superstition
it's a superstition for chess players
that your birthday is the day you lose
it's happened to me before i remember
losing to greg shahadi on my birthday
it's the same tournament i got my final
gm norm and made the grandmaster title
but but that loss was my second round
loss all my birthdays it's like happy
birthday
do you think about that yeah i've lost
on my birthday before i think a couple
of times uh
i think 2007
and i was
13 years old i lost my birthday
yeah you never forget we cried we cried
also i beat hiker on his birthday in
london five years ago
so that was memorable ah well
uh the thing is
you just work you gotta be you gotta be
strong you gotta be tough and uh you
gotta play a good game and try not to
lose i think that's
the worst possible way to celebrate your
birthday yeah you don't you don't forget
them uh but i'm very glad it's a rest
day tomorrow
um
you just gotta give your all we all know
the uf championship is a very tough
tournament yeah we gotta get fighting
every game but yeah preferably don't
play a thurman near bert dan
wesley you're the defending champion you
got four rounds under your belt in the
open section uh which players to your
mind standing out after four rounds are
you looking around at the competition
your thoughts
yeah uh i think lanier is very strong
he's improved a lot uh he's
he's played magnificent chess in the
last two months last three months so
he's a very very strong player
i think he his rating can go higher than
what it is currently
um
fab is the top seed but i think he's a
bit tired he's not in his hundred
percent discernment he's making
mistakes which he never he never would
yeah i mean he's had dubious positions
but still of the only 2800 determined
he's still the favorite
i
i think ray robson is playing very well
also
his rating has been quite stagnant the
last few years he hasn't played any over
the board chess
maybe played only one overboard just in
two years so but he's playing
uh really well and
you gotta like his position in the game
right now against jeffrey yeah i'm a bit
surprised with what's happening with
jeffrey jeffrey has a lot of promise
his rating was very high but the last
few months haven't been so kind to him
but uh is it what equal but yeah i'd say
that lanier
uh fabian and robinson are are very
those are the players you really are
are looking at yeah
yeah also also sam but sam shankland has
played has been playing non-stop for the
last five months so i think he's a bit
tired as well
last uh quick question uh sam savion
yeah nice uh surprise junior player type
of first if he plus one
yeah and he's still playing yeah yeah
yeah no he's very strong very aggressive
i have a terrible result
with him he beat me in 2015
when he was like 13 years old
i remember i remember that game he
wanted black uh he's
very aggressive very intimidating he's
big and he's wide and he's just a scary
opponent
[Laughter]
and yeah he's a very attack aggressive
player but
sounds like you're describing a ufc
right right right like wrestlemania
yeah fabian's very intimidating he
stands uh right in front of you after
you made this move
it's always tough but somehow i don't
know why he's rating us and
he's been a bit inconsistent
the last few years but he's always
dangerous uh
but let's see i guess jeffrey is in
trouble again has he assumed against ray
robson yes
thank you wesley good luck in the rest
of the tournament enjoy your free day
get your ass yeah thank you absolutely
um